second big league start for dan castano
his major league debut was last weekend
against the mets he took the loss four
and a third gave up home runs to michael
conforto and pete alonso but really who
hasn't at this point so two aboard
that'll bring up adam duvall and a ball
grounded to the left side scooped up at
third base by eddie alvarez shoots it
over the first and castano's out of
trouble max freed's three and owen
rolling to start this year yeah set to
make his fifth start of the year you see
his numbers there 3-0 with a 1-5-9 p-r-a
cervelli three homers seven rbis
on the ground toward camargo second base
one catcher running the turn in time and
freed gets three outs via ground ball
and works a scoreless bottom of the
first in miami he'll face marco reilly
and danny echeverria
there goes the bat look out into the
netting above the marlins dugout a
strikeout for castano one away what a
way for austin reilly cisco wants him to
bounce a breaking ball he's pointing it
there he goes again he's pointing at
home plate he wants the ball down get it
down
he did and it leads to a strikeout
and that's the second miami hit lewis
brinson and the marlins have a second
inning threat on the ground too short
dansby
with the throw to first and freeman with
the stretch and that will retire the
sides the base runner for the hottest
braves hitter travis garneau on one one
there no bounce one to the right of
shorts a nice backhand pick we are to
second for one back to first foresight
double play in and over and over six
four three inning ender
two balls and two strikes on aguilar two
outs with a runner at third base the
offering from freed got him swinging
strike three came in with that slider
and he picks up his first strikeout of
the ball game backs free to work in the
bottom of the fourth inning the three
four five hitters for the marlins are
coming up and the cutter got him and
cervelli's retired that's the second
strikeout for freed in a row second of
the game one out anderson pounced out
his first time up
tipped and caught and anderson is
retired three straight strikeouts for
max freed
and two are out in the marlins fourth
logan forsyth bounced out and 92 top of
the zone forsyth can't lay off and max
free just struck out the side and now
camargo this single shot it the other
way and austin riley will be the batter
austin riley
swings at the first one out to right
bertie racing oh make the catch on the
slide throws to first and they double up
camargo
speed plays on defense too and you just
saw it it is awesome camargo my goodness
completely sold out thought this was
gonna drop watch the jump that birdie
gets the closing speed the athleticism
and then the
instinct to
nail his man at first base in camargo
who definitely wandered way off just two
hits he has struck out the last four
marlins hitters and in the miami fifth
he starts with brinson as that one's
caught on a missed he struck out five
straight
a one out walk
and the batter is eddie alvarez
curveball back door swinging a miss he
chased a bad ball way out in front and
max has his sixth strikeout
just like castano did in the first
inning he'll face freddie freeman here
with
nobody on base and two outs
here's a 3-2 and freeman whacks it hard
diving stop nice play foresight throws
to first for the out a terrific play
logan forsyth takes a hit away from
freddie freeman
no score each starter three hits shut
out through
six innings of work zozuna launches that
one deep toward left field that ball's
got a chance and it's gone ozuna the
braves cleanup man has broken the
deadlock a solo home run his fifth of
the year and atlanta has finally taken
the lead tiny bit up one hand came off
the bat a little bit still strong enough
to drive it in the seat and max free
goes to work to malita off walk for free
he's not going and it's caught on a miss
late swing by forsyth who didn't
recognize that pitch and that is
strikeout number seven one and one to
brinson
and that's a base hit
to duvall in left field
well the marlins have a chance now max
freed's day is done shane green but a
couple of inherited base runners here in
the bottom of the seventh and one down
little rollover towards second echeveria
two second for one dansby held the bag
did a somersault over the bag and might
have gotten a piece of brinson as he
slid on by and brinson
did enough to
keep the braves from trying to make that
throw to first so the inning stays alive
first and third with two outs
[Applause]
strike three that's at the top of the
zone and max freed said yeah that's
three yeah get him out of here way to go
shane will smith he'll face monte
harrison to lead things off monte with a
drive right center field long run
inciarte goodbye home run
first for monte harrison and it ties the
game in the eighth oh
juvalo for three struck out his last
time up that ball is hammered deep
toward left field did he get enough did
he keep it fair it's off the pole
adam duvall wheaton reached down and
pokes it down the left field line
kinsler can't believe it and atlanta
with a second solo home run takes the
lead in the ninth
well lewin diaz has found the batters
box this is his first major league
played appearance
and he's up to the task a base hit the
first for lewin diaz
marlon's have the tying run on and now
miami brings the winning run to the
plate and matt joyce the hitter and
joyce hits a high fly ball to center
pretty deep but not deep enough and the
brave streak is over malanson nails it
down and the braves play a very
clean complete game that was beautiful